riley martin was the best he had the
weirdest evolution on the show he went
from
like phone caller the guy called me and
said he
speaks to aliens so i said okay you know
we'll call you back tomorrow morning oh
i see
are you an alien yourself i was picked
up
you were you were abducted you were you
abducted by aliens
i was visited then i had him on the show
this gentleman's name is
riley take a seat riley and his look was
great
and his whole rap that voice you know
you knew howard
i was captured by aliens when i was a
young man
and now why do you think they came to
you did you ever ask the aliens this
they rarely abduct people at random
they have a purpose it would seem that i
have a genetic trait
that's a hold up from their first mixing
with the elohim
with man i see and they made it with
humans they first
made it with the
when they found that they could not get
home nor clone themselves
right he's a true character and i was
actually fascinated not only by him but
by the people who
hung out with him he had a whole cadre
of people who bought into the fact
that he was somehow abducted by aliens
how did riley uh
court you yeah i mean it's an amazing
story i pursued him
did you were you a believer in what he
had to say about him being
uh taken away by space aliens a lot of
people don't believe you know you
believe
you believe harwood miraculous things
happen
when you mess with the space cowboy
synchronicity everything about him was
interesting his anger with me
he wanted to be paid a million dollars
for his radio show that he did for us
and then his
on-air negotiations with me riley wrote
me this
letter about how he's decided that he
will re-up his contract
under what conditions he wants two weeks
paid vacation
he's the whole life is a vacation all of
san jose
uh will you comply with my
simple request no that's all i can get
out of you
yes that's it uh i am
probably the only one who love you what
are you saying
why are you being mean to me i gave you
no what i'm saying
is that if you love me let me know
[ __ ]
everything about him was great the voice
this is uh my
intentions is to uh attempt to save the
planet
the attitude my ulterior motive is to
get girls
also negotiating
don't you think riley complains too much
to me
about money shouldn't he leave the show
but it was also real to him and raw
it's hard to believe he's gone you know
we've had a lot of big celebrities on
this show but
riley martin is still one of the most
outstanding and remembered guests
because he was real he kept it real on
the air and that's what you look for on
a radio show
though i have sat on the forward deck of
an x6
and warped through the hyperspace
windows
and came barrel rolling out into the
brilliance of some primordial have not
found anything in the cosmos
that moves me like earth women there you
go yeah robin now you're going to happen
that was good that was very good riley
martin
so missed
you